no es casualidad este movimiento que
estamos viendo en el mundo del arte en
respecto a cuba ya a finales de 2020
hubo cientos de artistas que
protagonizaron una importante
manifestación en la habana y
recientemente vimos el caso de júnior
garcía quien partió a españa qué peso
tiene el mundo de la del arte y de la
cultura en este momento como oposición
al gobierno cubano
buenas noches el peso es importantísimo
los actores los artistas han sido en
cuba quienes organizaron masivas
protestas quienes han denunciado a
través del arte a través de las redes
sociales las violaciones de derechos
humanos en el país y una clara
consecuencia de eso es que las protestas
del 11 de julio que fueran las más
masivas desde la revolución cubana fuego
miles de personas cantando parte y vida
que fue una de las canciones
emblemáticas
exigiendo una mejora en la situación de
derechos humanos una canción que
casualmente ganó hace poco el un grammy
latinos a mejor canción
tamara teniendo en cuenta lo que usted
nos está diciendo cuál es el panorama
entonces para aquellos artistas que no
están en línea con el ejecutivo y no
tiene la posibilidad de abandonar la
isla tienen ustedes cifras de arrestos y
detenciones
en los últimos meses alrededor de 50
artistas han sido perseguidos penalmente
o sometidos a prisión domiciliaria o
encarcelados la situación de lo que
hemos visto es que la respuesta a las
críticas de los artistas por parte del
régimen cubano ha sido
sistemáticas violaciones de derechos
humanos los han detenido o los han
sometidos a procesos penales arbitrarios
a muchos los obligan a irse a tener que
exiliarse o les imponen una prisión
domiciliaria de facto porque no los
dejan salir de su casa o incluso les
cortan internet para que queden
incomunicados este es el tipo de cosas
que está dispuesto a hacer el régimen
cubano para silenciar a los artistas que
a través de su arte están cuestionando
la falta verdades básicas como
consecuencias reales creen que pueda
tener este comunicado este llamado de
atención permite un gobierno que
directamente niegue este tipo de
acusaciones el propósito de este
pronunciamiento es exigirle al régimen
cubano que libere a quienes están
arbitrariamente detenidos en cuba que
existe los procesos penales abusivos que
hay abiertos en contra de ellos y que
también permita a quienes están en el
exilio volver a cuba a mostrar suerte la
realidad que esto es un consenso de más
de 300 artistas en todo el mundo durante
mucho tiempo el régimen cubano ha
tratado de usar artistas y algunos
artistas para mostrar que la situación
lengua en realidad no está tan mal y lo
que hoy vemos es que hay más de 300
artistas muy reconocidos como
mencionadas al comienzo que han dicho ya
basta y esto no es una cuestión política
esto es una cuestión muy elemental de
libertad de expresión que esperamos que
tenga de echos
en las sociedades a nivel global